معنا همم في استوديو التغطيه هنا من داخل
مقر انعقاد المنتدى الرئيس التيوانيه
جيتانوس ناوسيدا
لنستكشف اكثر همم الموقف الليتواني وكذلك
موقف اعضاء حلف شمال الاطلسي النيته
والاتحاد الاوروبي من التوتر الجاري في
اوكرانيا حاليا سياده الرئيس مرحبا بك
لماذا يبدو موقفكم اكثر تشددا من بقيه
الدول الاوروبيه الكبيره دائما ما تحمل
تصريحاتكم قدرا من الضغوط على الدول من
اجل امداد اوكرانيا باسلحه متطوره
موقفا
نعم نحن
مهتمون بدعم اوكرانيا
المزيد من الجهود من بلدان الاتحاد
الاوروبيه
ان تحقق النصر فيها نحن نعيش في منطقه
حساسه الاسوانيه لديها تاريخ طويل في
التعامل مع روسيا ومع الجيران
كبار وطيله الوقت واجهنا الكثير من
التهديدات من هذه البلدان ليس فقط
واقتصاديه ومن خلال الاعتماد على مصادر
الطاقه وحاولنا على مد
ى ان نتحرر من هذا الاعتماد وقد استثمرنا
في محطه الغاز الطبيعي المثال واقمنا ايضا
اتصالات
وفولندا
وقد استطعنا في ابريل من العام الماضي
قلنا ان انا مستعده لقطع الاعتماداتنا في
مجال الطاقه على روسيا لهذا سبب من اجل
الحريه
في اوروبا هذا لهذا سبب منخرطه بهذا
القضيه بهذه الدرجه
ايضا كنتم من اكثر الدول الضاغطه باتجاه
تزويد او زياده العقوبات المفروضه على
روسيا في هذه المرحله الا تخشون من
استفزاز روسيا في هذه الحرب مساله حتميه
انتصار اوكرانيا هذه حذر منها حتى سياسي
مخضرم مثل هنري كيسنجر
روسيا في الزاويه والضغط عليها بهذه
الصوره فيه اهانه الامه الروسيه الكبيره
هذه دوله كبيره وهذه قوه عظمى يعني لا
تعدم الاوراق للضغط هي الاخرى على الجانب
الاوروبي ما خطوتكم ما رؤيتكم
مصر يجب ان يكون هناك تداعيات والنتائج
لهذا السلوك العدواني الشديد من روسيا نحن
لسنا مستعدين للحديث
اي مفاوضات السلام سيكون
علامه البدل في عمليه السلام تحدثتم عن
العقوبات الاقتصاديه نحن نفهم من العقوبات
الاقتصاديه ليست كافيه لتغيير عقليه
وسلوكيات روسيا لكنها تثمر عن بعض النفاس
حتى الان اجماليه الناتج المحليه الروسي
هذا العام
قال وربما حتى النشاط الاقتصادي الروسي في
العام المقبل لكن بالطبع هذا ليس كافيا
وهذه هي ليست سوا واحده من الادوات التي
نحاول من خلالها جعل لروسيا تفكر بتغييره
موقفها وتغييره سلوكها
لكنها تصريحاتكم تذهب ابعد من هذا قلتم ان
اوكرانيا ستنتصر وان انتصارها سيغير وجه
القاره الاوروبيه حدث هذا منك في الجلسه
الاولى التي كنت مشاركا فيها قبل يومين
هنا في ذا فويس مساله الانتصار وحتميه
انتصار اوكرانيا تعني حتميه هزيمه روسيا
ثم ان مساله الرفض المطلق لعقد محادثات
سلام او تقبل وساطه مثل التي عرضتها تركيا
على الجانبين الروسي والاوكراني التشدد في
هذا الموقف يعني عدم نهايه الحرب لان
روسيا ربما نفاسها طويل في هذه الحرب
وكذلك في الجهه الاخرى همم حلف شمال
الاطلسي ربما نفسه طويل هل هناك اي افاق
لانهاء هذه الحرب
بالليل
اوكرانيا قادر على الانتصار في هذه الحرب
لكن ليس لوحدها اذا ما دعمنا اوكرانيا بكل
الوسائل كما قلت ليس فقط العسكريه بل ايضا
بالوسائل الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه سوف
نساعدهم
هلا اعاده بناء البنيه التحتيه المدنيه هم
الناجحون في ميدان المعركه وهم قادرون على
الكسر هذا الحرب كم ستدوم هذه الحرب انا
لا استطيع الاجابه لان المساله المعقده
نرى كيف ان ال-
نظام الكرامه
في هذه الحرب مهما كانت الكلفه ومهما كان
ذلك على حسابي المجتمع الروسي في ظل هذه
الظروف سيكون صعب ان نقول ان الحب ستنتهي
في اشهر ربما
علينا ان نبذ لقصاره جهدنا لمساعدته
اوكرانيا كما لا تساوروني اي اوهام ان
روسيا ستتوقف عند اقران روسيا ستكون لها
اهداف اخرى مثل الجامع الاوروبي
لاحتلها بعد اوكرانيا او يشنون الحرب
عليها بعد اوكرانيا
يعني يبدو ان الدول الكبرى في القاره
الاوروبيه لا تشارككم نفس وجهه النظر او
نفس هذا الموقف الذي وصفناه وصف بالمتشدد
والا لما يعني ترددت المانيا في امداد
اوكرانيا على سبيل المثال الدبابات
المتطوره التي تحتاجها
5 فور 6
سنوات روسيا لم تكن لديها اي خطه مهاجمه
اوكرانيا وكل التصريحات قالت ليست لدينا
اي خطط في
انفسكم
فيما يتعلقوا بتصريحات الانظمه السلطه
القويه
والاستبداديه لانهم يقولون شيئا علنا وفي
واقع الحال يفعلون شيئا مختلفا لهذا السبب
نحن لا ثقه لدينا بالتصريحات الكلاميه
لنظام الكراملا وعلينا ان نستعد وان نعزز
امننا
للانفاق على الجوانب الدفاعي اكثر نسوانيه
وبلدان
انضمت الى النيته في 2004
نحن نتمتع بهذا السقف سقف النظام المنظومه
الدفاعيه المشتركه وهذا امر مهم لامننا
لكن علينا ان نفعل اكثر من ذلك لكان
نستطيع التصدي لهذا الضغط القادم من الشرق
[موسيقى]
قلتم انكم تريدون ان يعيد الكريم لن تقييم
الموقف ويعيد التفكير واعاده النظر في
الحرب برمتها لكن كيف يمكن ان تعرف نوايا
الكريملين وروسيا مغيبه عن كل المحافل
الدوليه هنا ليس لها تمثيل في ذا فويس لم
تدعى اصلا الى هذا المنتدى
الرياضيه تستبعد روسيا من هذا كيف يمكن
للانصات لوجهه النظر الروسيه حتى يتم
التعامل مع هذا الامر بشكل صحيح واقامه
الحسابات على همم على اسس سليمه
ايه قص السمر
المتحده مجلس الامن الدولي على سبيل
المثال
كما ان هناك
ايضا
مناقشات على مستوى ثنائي وحوار ثنائي مع
نظامي نعم هناك ايضا بعض الشروط المسبقه
على الحوار بين روسيا واوكرانيا لكن مع
وجود شروط مسبقه بان لا يكون هناك
ضغط ثياب بان على اوكرانيا
ماذا يعني ذلك الا يعني ذلك ان القوات
الروسيه داخل في اراضي البلد مستقل وتريد
البقاء فيها واذا ما حاولت
اوكرانيا ام تقدمه هذه التنازلات في
الاراضي هذا يعني
الاضرار بسلامه اراضي واقليم اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا بلد مستقله السياده وعليه
ويستطيع ان يقرر مصيره هذا حق طبيعي لكل
بلد ولكل امه
شكرا جزيلا لك سياده الرئيس
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه مشاهدينا
الكرام شكرا جزيلا لكم ايضا على حسن
المتاب